we need to view ourselves not as
consumers or members of political tribes
but citizens of Earth the still evolving
tangle of old recycled sun-powered and
profoundly interdependent dancing parts
there's a teaching attributed to the
18th century Polish Hasidic rabbi simcha
boon him that for me a very lapsed and
deeply agnostic Scandinavian Lutheran
carries great wisdom one should carry
two slips of paper one in your left
pocket reading I am ashes and dust the
other in the right reading the world was
made for me both are true somewhere
between the poles of existential despair
and narcissistic self absorption lies
the path that will take us back to the
center of the cosmos but our Holocene
snow day is ending now and no one is
going to be waiting us waiting for us
with a warm supper it's time to grow up
and with a clear-eyed view of both past
and future resolved to become better
ancestors and start making up for so
much lost time
[Applause]
you